Marty's leaving to Buffalo tomorrow guys
10 years to the day since you've been
back so no since I left
oh isn't you moved so it's weird yeah
it's gonna be a weird time warp for you
yeah man I remember I I like we had the
U-Haul packed my mom's on the porch I
was just like I'm Gonna Make It Happen
she's like I know
[__] her and that was it
drove off into the [__] sunset with
all her [__] in a Airbnb ahead of us
wow 10 years later
um
10 years of my mind was like the real
like if I get 10 years between me and
buffalo I'll have kind of established
myself weird
this was everything I could have
imagined like best case scenario by far
the way everything's coming together
way back when
when everything seemed [__] hopeless
and I was convincing myself I was a
[__] billionaire
nobody looked at me like I was crazy
like this is best case scenario so sick
all right so you're gonna go back